I think he had some idea but probably
not not the full extent yeah right there
was probably you know probably the fact
that they were willing to sell Twitter
to him should have told him they were
just I mean it was just it was just you
know Jack Dorsey all these other people
it was you know they were just these
figureheads and it was I mean the
inmates were running the Asylum yeah and
uh and it was it was probably on some
level
you know you know there was some part of
it that was somewhat ideological there
was a way that uh Elon felt like the
wrong person ideologically to take over
Twitter but I mean after after a decade
of the stock going nowhere they were
just completely exhausted
years ago once off camera you said to me
I wouldn't be a Libertarian if any of it
worked and I just thought that line
pretty much captures so much of what's
Happening even right this moment you
referenced the last three years of
covered where it seems like nothing
really works anymore our government kind
of doesn't work our educational
institutions don't seem to work the the
medical field doesn't seem to work
is it all is it sort of obvious that
they were all not going to work at the
exact same time or how did this happen
well I'm you know I'm tempted to say the
rod has been building up for a long time
uh and you know if you Define technology
as doing more with less
um so many of uh these institutions
educational and even Health Care are are
kind of the opposite where you get the
same for more or you get less for more
so it's the anti-tech definition right
the public schools probably in some
sense the quality of the education is is
way lower than it was 50 or 60 years ago
the costs are way higher and so it's it
is you're getting less for more and uh
and then there are you know versions of
us with Healthcare where maybe maybe
people are getting a little bit better
health care than they were 30 years ago
but at Double the cost so it's again uh
you know a lot of it's sort of like a 80
socialist Health Care system that we
have not 100 but but 80 and there's a
lot of a lot of stuff that's screwed up
with that so yeah I think I think there
are a lot of things that had not been
working for for quite some time and
maybe the the interesting question is
why people weren't noticing it or
something like that yeah so what do you
think that is is that just our modern
lives we're staring at our phones all
day we're watching TV shows and we're
just not paying attention
there were still some parts of our
society where things were progressing
and there was certainly some
um maybe narrow cone of progress around
computers software internet mobile
internet
um and then um those parts where there
was still progress and where things were
were still getting better also Were
Somehow distracting us from the lack of
progress everywhere else the ways in
which we're not a progressive Society we
use the word Progressive gets used all
the time but it doesn't stand for actual
progress and you know I always say you
know the the uh the the iPhones that um
you know distract us from our
environment also distract us from the
way it's strangely old so you're looking
at an iPhone while you're writing a 100
year old Subway that's completely bust
in New York and so there's something
about we have some elements of progress
but they've they've been uh distracting
us from you know the lack of progress or
even the outright Decline and then um
and then together with some kind of
crazy crystallizing event like like
kobit where you know you have
no science no rationality
um you know you can't it takes a long
time to even get the vaccine approved
you know the FDA is just a blocker all
these things you know don't work that
well they still work relatively better
in the US than many other countries but
uh but all sorts of things are really
off so as the guy that was the first
outside investor in Facebook and sort of
you know at the beginning of the of the
tech boom 20 something years ago were
you thinking about some of that then or
was anyone talking about the fact that
we might all get distracted by so much
information and so much nonsense and
scrolling and all this stuff that
everything else will just kind of slide
away and we won't even know like was
there any inkling of some of that well I
did I did I didn't
you know I I think it's always a little
bit unfair to to um put too much of the
blame on on Silicon Valley for this
where um you know there was some
innovation in Silicon Valley there was a
sense in which it probably was not not
quite enough you know there was a this
Manifesto that um my Venture Capital
fund put out and back in 2011 where the
tagline was you know they promised us
flying cars and all we got was 140
characters and that wasn't it wasn't
meant as an anti-twitter argument per se
like Twitter you know it's a good
business it's good for the several
thousand people that work there maybe
there were slightly too many but yeah um
or at least for the several thousand
that are left it's a good business it's
uh
um and you know it somehow was
transformative in some way but it's
wasn't enough to you know take our whole
civilization to the next level and this
was so so I think Silicon Valley was was
doing some things but it was not enough
and then you know there were arguments
that you know it didn't have to all be
in Silicon Valley you know they were
going they weren't building flying cars
in Silicon Valley they weren't building
playing Carlos anywhere else right so
since you mentioned Twitter let's just
do an Elon thing for a second as you
watch the guy buy this thing obviously
you guys did PayPal together and
everything else do you think he realized
what a freaking headache this thing was
going to become and and how how crazy
the product under the hood actually was
there was probably
there was probably uh I I I I'm I've
been talking about the the Twitter
um the Twitter acquisition I think that
uh
or just broadly speaking figure finding
that so many of these things are sort of
broken under the hood in a way
I I think I think he had some idea but
probably not not the full extent yeah
right there was probably you know
probably the fact that they were willing
to sell Twitter to him should have told
him they were just I mean it was just it
was just you know Jack Dorsey all these
other people it was you know they were
just these figureheads and it was I mean
the inmates were running the Asylum yeah
and uh and it was it was probably on
some level
you know you know there was some part of
it that was somewhat ideological there
was a way that uh Elon felt like the
wrong person ideologically to take over
Twitter but I mean after after a decade
of the stock going nowhere they were
just completely exhausted yeah you can
only lose money for so long I don't know
that much about business but they didn't
lose money but they didn't if you look
at the Twitter price the day
at the end of the first day of trading
so you know price the IPO it closes on
day one and I forget what the exact
number was oh I think it was it was
roughly the same right it's roughly the
same as at the point where Elon offered
to acquire it so it had gone nowhere in
a decade yeah in a context where a lot
of tech stocks had gone up so I think
they were they were just completely
exhausted and and it was sort of a plea
for help and then Elon probably on some
level realized it and Ensemble didn't
realize quite how you know please take
this company from us and uh and you know
you can hear that as uh Elon you're
wonderful you can do a great job or uh
we're just really really exhausted right
probably some combination of both right
so all right so let's shift a little bit
I want to talk to you one of the things
that we've covered an awful lot on my
show in the last two months is is a lot
of the the globalist stuff and the wef
and the meetings in Davos and all of
these things and I always try to say
when I'm doing these things on the show
it's like I I don't have a full sense of
how much influence these organizations
actually have verse is just they give
these crazy speeches we all kind of
freak out about it but what are actually
the policies and then on the other hand
you see someone maybe like a Justin
Trudeau who seems like he really is
incorporating a lot of the policies of
the wef so as someone that you you've
been to some of these things over the
years right like what do you make of
what actually goes on there I assume
you're usually kind of on the outside
even if you're there yeah just because
of your political leader I I went to the
wef three times 2008 2009 2013. so I
haven't been in about a decade
um
it is
I mean there's things about it that are
maybe maybe talking some about global
globalism generally none it is it is
somehow this official ideology it is
it's in some ways very exhausted so it's
I think the tide is going out the high
Watermark year was probably 2007 and
it's been going out in some way for 16
years but it's been going out very very
slowly and um and there are sort of ways
that uh it is
um you know in theory
um you know a borderless more integrated
more peaceful world is is a good world
for the 21st century that's good
globalization right and then there are
all kinds of versions of it that are
kind of bad where it just ends up being
you know a a racket for
um you know dictators stealing money and
stashing it in Swiss bank accounts which
probably were Davos you can think of as
a sort of reputation laundering
operation or something like that yeah or
they're all sorts of versions of it that
are you know um uh deeply deeply
unhealthy and I think it has been on
this this kind of autopilot where it
just keeps going even though it's very
exhausted I think it's been exhausted
for for 15 years if you're looking for a
more unfiltered lens into the World of
Tomorrow check out our Tech playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a wide variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of future videos be sure
to subscribe and click the notification
Bell